okay what up guys welcome to the jess
pearly things youtube channel um today
i'm in a slightly different location
same coffee cup
and my top my talk of the day
is about people
and their habit
is my washer too loud i hope it's not
too hopefully it's okay hopefully you
can still hear me it can get kind of
loud and because i'm an american i live
in the uk
the washers here they'd be they'd be so
loud it's crazy anyways
anyways i'm gonna continue hold on
so
i always try to quit coffee and i never
do i never do i started coffee at 21
okay
didn't drink before that
and
drink coffee
and
after 21 i was addicted okay
now i drink it all the time in the past
four years i'm 25 now i've been trying
to quit
unsuccessfully
unsuccessful okay
and why am i telling you this what does
this have to do with like people
is people have patterns in their
relationships they have a core that they
always go back to
um
and it's really hard to change that
and i say this to someone
i quit drinking right
and there's always going to be a part of
me that wants to drink and loves getting
drunk and loves getting effed up
and this is coming from someone that i
haven't even drank heavily since i was
21 22.
and that's it's still in you
and
what does this matter right like what
what am i talking about
it's the same thing with selfish people
people
i've found often that times in life i'm
a very nice person and people might you
know see my videos and think i'm rude or
whatever
i have my flaws but in general i'm a
very good friend and i'm very
nice to the people that i care about and
i do a lot for them and anyone that's
been friends with me since i was
a kid like i have one friend i kind of
had a falling out with a couple years
ago
and people that i have falling out
without with usually come back and
apologize because
in general
i was a good friend and time shows that
so
like for example when i was like 16 i
made this girl a scrapbook
of like
like a very per like it was and she said
to this day that one of the nicest gifts
she's ever received right
that's just
how i am how i've always been and there
was a time in my life where i like hated
this about myself because i was like i
am so nice to people and kind
and i feel like i get walked all over
and part of that was my own fault right
part of that was it was it was
definitely me because
you have to learn how to stand up for
yourself and you have to learn how to
have a backbone and that's just
something
i don't know naturally i didn't grow up
with a ton of conflict like my parents
generally got along
um me and my siblings got along for the
most part like i grew up between two
boys and i would say
in my family those are the two guys i'm
like the closest to like i just don't
that doesn't come naturally to me it's
just not my thing
but
and i kind of am enamored a little bit
by people that are a little bit like
rough on the edges like
um
i'm pretty out there so i kind of like
people that are kind of out there and
sometimes
those people can be a little nuts
um but usually the people like that are
kind of interesting but the problem is
those same people
can be can be solved people in general
are selfish
and
i'm not above that right like can i ever
be selfish yes of course
of course
anyways so but what i've realized in
life
toxic people can't outrun themselves
they can't
they will go the rest of their life
in different relationships with the same
patterns
and it is very rare to see these people
switch
so if you meet a guy or girl and they've
had toxic relationship
after toxic relationship
usually in the future it'll be toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
it just is what it is
and this is coming from someone
i've been in one
but
not having a backbone isn't a good thing
right anyways
so what's my point in this sometimes
when we feel like we're too nice
we feel like we get taken advantage of
and sure we do in the short term but in
the long term like selfish people don't
win they don't
and i know this because i grew up in a
wealthy family and all of the most
successful people that i know are like
are honestly the most kind and generous
people like my parents
are so nice like they these are
don't don't be wrong they drive me nuts
sometimes but these these are
my parents are probably top three most
successful people i've ever met
they
they took in three teenagers that
they weren't even looking to like adopt
and these kids were just in bad
situations they took them in who does
that genuinely like kind people
and
the reason i think this is is because in
order to get to the top and build
something great and big you can't be
selfish you have to make the people feel
around you feel like they're in a
mutually beneficial relationship and i
think of trump okay
trump
people can love him or hate him but the
people that loved trump or ride or die
don't get me wrong he fired everybody
um
but
but the people that are like team trump
are team trump all the way like they are
ride or dies and
it's because trump found a way to make
those people feel like they were in a
mutually benef beneficial relationship
and this made me think of the time i was
in
milwaukee okay and in milwaukee i
decided i wanted to interview successful
people so i called up
big corporations i worked in sales so i
had like
the corporation's numbers all in one
place and
just asked if i could interview like
some of their executives and how they
were so successful and
i called 50
executives right i don't know if i
actually got their voicemail they
listened to whatever out of 50
three
no two two responded which in sales
that's like a really good close rate and
that's a really good close rate
for
one of the most successful people in the
company like i interviewed this lady um
who the cio of harley davidson and
she was so nice she was like literally
so nice and
that's what i mean like
i found the most successful people are
not they're not they're not selfish and
if they are
they make the people around them feel
like
there's something in it for them
like they they make the people around
them feel like they're in a mutual
mutually beneficial relationship and i
asked all of these executives like
who who succeeds more
um the smartest people the
hardest working and they said no
it's the people like it to rise up to
the top of these companies you have to
be good with people
and you you hack
and
um
yeah
so
sure selfish people
win in the short term but they do not
win in the long term like they will have
these same toxic patterns the rest of
their life
and you have to learn to cut these
people off you have to because they will
i'll take you down um
and the other thing is selfish people
that do start to make it to the top you
burn enough people and you're successful
jealousy's a [ __ ] man people come after
you like my parents are like genuinely
the kindest people i've ever met in my
life
and people came after them
but they couldn't
because
you're not gonna find [ __ ] on my parents
and that's why i so confidently like
come on the internet and say my dad
doesn't cheat he doesn't do any of that
[ __ ] because
you won't find [ __ ] on my parents you
literally won't
um so i don't know i this i'm telling
you guys this used to bother me so much
where i felt like i was too nice and
it's still something i work on but
in the long in the long term like you're
gonna live to be 80 okay
let's say
if you're kind to people you're
considerate you're polite you're
respectful
and you think of other people along the
way like
you're gonna make it farther than being
selfish and self-centered you are and
look it guys i have had so many people
i'm not i don't even consider myself
like a success story but i've had so
many people help me
with [ __ ]
just over the years like i had a couple
from my church
let me live with them for 200 a month to
save to come to england and i swear to
god if i ever make it big like i don't
know what i'm gonna get for them but
they will get something like
the nicest people fed me
but he did all this [ __ ] for me
anyways
selfish people
have patterns and they don't win not in
the long run
maybe maybe a time or two here or there
but
you can't run from yourself
and
eventually who you are catches up to you
so
that's why we have more incentive than
either ever to be a good person
because
with the internet
people aren't going to be able to hide
[ __ ] anymore
one screenshot
ruin your life so
anyways
subscribe
i love you all appreciate you all and
let me know in the comments what topic
you'd like me to cover next in my
morning coffee chats
bye